listening to
david and carry water
they talk with you
and I printer on the treats I ran away
from Washington State while I was on
probation and I was running from just a
lot a whole bunch of trouble I was
happening at home which was me to start
hearing with some other usual teen
problems that a lot of teenagers have
with their parents I could see in him
that he's the type of person that would
do anything to help anybody and even
though me having the history I have of
not being able to trust a lot of men I
can feel the whole total totally
different vibe with him really
unexplainable how I kind of got close to
these kids and I think there's part of
the street family that they all live
with is this family of them and once you
get in with one of them they kind of see
that they they trust you and but when I
finally met them there was like
something told me this is something
that's gonna help you you needed to let
yourself open on this so I mean I put
myself out there and look what happened
i'm off the streets now because they all
of them say oh I liked being out here
you know it's a pride thing and they
don't want anyone feeling sorry for them
but most these kids were abused don't
have family would kids with their
parents are doing math to them and they
were eight and five and one kid has
dropped off at a rest stop at night like
literally he was going on a road trip
with his parents and they brought him to
rust optical the bathroom he came out
and were gone